uh let's start our second session today
and it is our pleasure to have Morgan
Austin we'll be talking about draft
embedding methods
thank you thank you for having me it's a
great pleasure to be here so today I
wanted to tell you about some of the
work I've done in the domain of machine
learning through learning on graphs so
this is very different a very different
side of my work than the one you got to
see yesterday and Peter stove it is
but I think there should be some
interest with some of you at least after
the discussion I've been having for the
last few weeks with some intersection
and so I was excited to talk about this
so there has been uh an explosion
okay there has been an explosion of
interest in machine learning for
learning on graphs and so this explosion
of Interest has led to an explosion of
methods through two main class of
methods that you're most familiar with
are probably not to vac and its
successes but were inspired by a natural
language processing methods and I'm
going to focus on those methods today
and then we're also work neural networks
I think someone is talking about it on
Friday I don't know if she's in a zoom
or not
um and but this explosion of Interest
has not been matched by a lot of theory
and so we know very little about those
algorithms what features of the graph
are we actually learning uh what is
their sense of consistency a weight of
convergence can give any guarantees how
much can we trust them on down on
Downstream tasks and you'll see there's
also a lot of ad hoc choices that are
made throughout the design of those
algorithms and there's not a lot of
theory to try to back those up and uh
we'll see actually that having some
sharing might make us change some of
those choices later on so this is kind
of a gap I was interested in feeling and
so this is mostly and this talk is going
to offer a piece of disposal and so this
is mainly based on joint work with
Andrew Davidson who was a PhD student at
Columbia University at the time and is
now I believe a research scientist at
Facebook meta very surprising uh and uh
when there's going to be at the end so
many materials because I love
prohibition I can help myself
so uh so what kind of tasks are
interesting for machine Learning
Community there's many different tasks
but the first one classical task is link
prediction so here you observe some
Network and we with some potentially
missing edges and when you want to use
the network structure to try to infer
some of those missing edges so a
classical example is the protein protein
interaction Network where every vertex
will represent a protein and there will
be an edge between two vertices if we
share some type of common biological
function
now there's a lot of proteins for which
we just don't know if they should be an
edge well between that if we share some
biological function
and so natural question is can we use a
part of a network but we do know about
to try to infer some of those missing
edges so this is linked prediction
the second classical problem is node
classification
so here you're going to observe some
graph let's say it could be a social
network and then you're going to observe
some additional information about uh
each vertex so for example it could be
the a if it's a social network uh the
age of a person it's employment it's
educational status and we're going to
call this provide information
and then in addition you might observe
some for certain vertices you're going
to observe some labels for example is
this personal Democrat or Republican and
for the others the labels are missing
and you want to use not only we could
write information but you also want to
use the network structure to try to
infer business in labels okay so this is
node classification there's a lot of
other tasks of interest uh the other one
that I know that most of you are very
familiar with is community detection
so doing machine learning on graph is
not trivial why because the structure of
graph data is discrete and if you think
about it most of the methods that you
know in machine learning have kind of
been designed under the assumption that
the data that you're going to see comes
in a form of a sequence of vectors
right this is for example the case when
neural networks and a graph is obviously
not breakable in the sequence of vectors
and so the solution that the community
has came up with
is to say okay we have this data but it
doesn't come in from a sequence of
vector let's transform it into a
sequence of vectors and you can do it
they do it in the following way they're
gonna map each vertex to a point in the
dimensional space that is supposed to
represent this vertex and this position
in the graph so two vertices two points
in the graph but uh in the dimensional
space that are going to be far away from
each other are going to correspond to
vertices but also far away from each
other for example not connected don't
share a lot of neighbors and points that
are crossed together in the dimensional
space should also be close together in
the graphene for example have a tendency
to be connected
uh here the dimension of a space d is
chosen often to be much smaller than the
number of vertices a traditional choice
in machine learning I believe is
128 to 256 this is the first example of
ad hoc choices this is a number that you
don't see throughout I think we all like
powers of two
um and so here we are going to represent
so here we put in the dimensional space
that is going to represent each vertex
is going to be called an embedding or an
embedding pattern now as well uh and the
mapping from the graph data to the
dimensional space we can call it a graph
embedding method
okay so imagine that now I have surgical
embedding method I know how to transfer
my data from a graph to a sequence of
vectors
then you want to do not classification
then what you can do is you can transfer
your data into a sequence of vectors and
then you can use I have a clarification
question then you embed so your vertices
also have labels or maybe features in
some so you keep those features on the
side
so here I'm just talking about so you
just embed the graph and in addition so
the vertex has sort of two compounds one
is the position in the graph and the
other is internal feature we provide
information yes indeed thank you for the
question and so now if you want to do
notification you can use for example a
new trainer neural network on your
embedded vectors and your covalent
information to do your node
classification
and so really here and then you're back
into the familiar realm of machine
learning and so we leave a move of a war
here is how are you going to produce
those embedding vectors this is the
growth part the West is not really the
black path anymore
and so obviously how to embed the graph
into yes so is that circle and a DOT an
inner or outer product
oh this one yeah this was a product
uh so here uh we so how to embed a graph
into a dimensional space obviously this
is a question that most of you have some
answers about who's a pretty good
Spectrum embedding methods have been
around and a very popular and successful
however uh they tend to sometimes not
scale very well for very large graph and
so they're not the type of methods that
have been favored by the machine
learning community
and so there's many different ways you
can do it but the top of our guac
embedding method that we are going to
talk about today are not too vac and
successes and we're gonna try to
establish a theory for using weddings
and understand what was the learning
beddings actually representing but
before I do and Define to you exactly
what notebook is we're gonna I'm gonna
show you that you can actually see this
through the legs of empirical risk
minimization and this is going to be
very useful to be able to produce some
Fury
minimization is the dominating framework
in machine learning and so in the
classical setting where you have a
sequence of ID observation and you want
you have a class of potential predictors
but for example index by certain weight
from certain weights
you are going to choose your prediction
with a long way you're going to choose a
loss function l and then you're going to
choose your predictor that minimizes
empirical risk or in other words the
empirical average of the losses over
your training data
okay and this ha and this has two main
identity the first one is simply that it
defines us principled way to define your
machine learning method you will notice
that here what we need to Define is uh
the search space for our predictors and
the loss function l
and the second advantage and is not
negligibly important is that you can use
stochastic gradient sets to be able to
efficient computationally efficiently
try to find the estimator even when your
search space is very large or when
you're training date you have a large
training size
um
brain data and stochastic gradient
descent is really the Workhorse of
machine learning it is extremely crucial
to machine learning being doable
and so an actual question is can you
extend this to graph data can you extend
the empirical risk minimization and the
circass equation to descent uh to uh to
setting of via data so this is the
question that was asked by Victor rich
and some coffers and I'm going to show
you how you can do that but before I can
do this
I'm going to first rephrase the
classical notion of the purpose
Communication in a way that is going to
make my definition more interesting so
imagine that you have some training data
X1 until xn and then I'm going to
General by SN a well-only chosen among
those then you will notice that the
conditional expectation of the losses
over Ascent were here are averaging out
on the random sampling there's nothing
else in the empirical risk why because
the probability that I have chosen the
if example is exactly one over n so if
you develop this formula you will obtain
exactly the empiricalesque and so during
empirical risk minimization is
equivalent to minimizing this
conditional expectation
and this is how you can try to extend it
to Glass so this is the key idea of
paper by Victor which
and Peter opens who's in the audience uh
and so here the idea we that we had was
that uh you could choose a random
sampling scheme that would take a guava
says n and we do and return one of size
K and then you can Define the empirical
whisk as the conditional expectation of
the losses over the sub graph where here
again you're averaging over you went on
something scheme
and doing empirical with minimization
it would be equivalent to minimizing
this empirical risk and then you can
once again and if you formulas
Exposition in this way you can do
actually stochastic bridge and descent
on graphs
and so
it's an emphatic now you have just met
the large government no and no this is a
this is the way if you rather than
sampling your minibatch right this is
the equivalent uh this is how
here to define the empirical risk I was
choosing one random point in my an
example and then I was completely lost
over this uh example and I was doing
this over and over again and the average
was giving me the empirical risk now I'm
defining I'm using the second skin to
Define green Poco risk
and so now that I have a definition of
an empirical risk I can choose my
embedding vectors to be such that they
will minimize this empirical risk and
you can freeze not to vac and all of its
successes in this way
and this is a powerful way to rephrase
things
so this is the main idea that we had and
so here you notice that to Define an
embedding method what do you need you
need to choose the dimension of a space
d versus function and something new
compared to the phase of our age
settings we also need to choose a
sampling scheme
something
which one in the expectation in the
second line Second bullet point music
yeah so unlike the simple case you're
not saying that this is that has the
quote correct expert expectation you're
saying this is your definition
you're not saying it's the same as the
expectation so this is the same it's the
same thing that is actually done by not
today and all of these methods it's just
a different way to say it but it's
another way to have some signage
originally but this is
I guess yeah I think so yes
and so now there's many ways you can
separate because not only one right you
could sample cave addresses and look at
the age of circle you could sample it
even verdict so for BCP delete the
isolated vertices and visit into server
you could sample edges or you could do a
random walk on your class so you could
for example
take a random walk or paste that so it
would allow you to sample K plus one
vertices now if a length of a row K is
not too big all of those vertices are
going to be very close together well
so maybe you also want to be able to
sample examples that are far away from
from that random work and so you can
also sample other exam other vertices
that are not necessarily connected to
the when a mooc and you can sample them
with a probability that will depend on
for example the degree levels of
vertices and this is a type of sampling
scheme that are considered in often
machine learning
some kind of picture
uh I'm I'm not sure that's interesting
but well for patreon you do a random
walk and every second step you choose a
random projects to start off working
which is random works you could choose
uniform or According to some other
distribution if it's another
distribution
to the last page right
right
um okay so now that we know we chose a
random sampling scheme the other thing
we needed to oh and uh so as I said this
is a type of sampling skin that often
considered in uh in machine learning for
example in deep work and you know to
back where they do a random walk for uh
k-step then look at the local engine
server obviously one is when I look and
then they also draw additional vertices
with a probability impact is a function
of a degree uh to hear free choice
reporter is also an ahead of choice but
it can lead to very interesting
properties
patreon of step one and step two
okay
some subtle differences but this is not
uh
and just one thing that I think I want
to make here that I would like to say
here is that the way you're sampling
here this random book is often so
positive sampling because it is
something it's how you're going to
sample example of vertices that are very
similar together and how you can in the
second step and how you're going to
sample vertices that are far away from
each other is often called uh negative
something in uh in the machine learning
literature okay so now that we've chose
how to sample a graph the second design
choice we have to make is the loss
function right and so uh as I said at
the beginning I want vertices that are
close together in the graph to be
represented by even adding vectors that
are similar and so for example if
vertices are connected I'm going to want
the dot products between embedding
vectors to be big
and this can be imposed for loss
function LP that is going to be big if
this dot product is small which we don't
want
and then if this is you and V are not
connected then we're gonna want the
product to be small because we want the
embedding vectors to be very different
and this is going to be enforced uh by
what do you mean by connected does it
mean they are in in the same connected
component in your small graph or do you
mean to have an edge between so there's
an edge between them yes there's an edge
between them
they need them to be connected I thought
so the point of this note to act was you
know like from text mining the reason
why cat and dog are the same is because
they appear in the same context
it isn't that they you know it isn't cat
and dog should have similar embeddings
because my pet is a cat my pet is a dog
they appear in similar context so as
soon connected is because they are yeah
I'm assuming connector and saying that
there's an edge between them now imagine
that they have your context matter that
they have a lot of common neighbors most
common neighbors are going to force them
also to have a similar embeddings okay
indirectly yes indirectly okay and so uh
so these dual constraints can be kind of
rephrase in the following way you can
have a loss function that if a vertices
you and they are connected I'm gonna
want the dot product to be small a big
sorry and if we are not connected I'm
going to want the dot products to be big
uh so I keep on Switching uh and so here
there's many different choices that you
could make for LP and Ln traditional
choices up across entropy losses in our
paper we consider over losses but now
throughout the rest of the talk I'm just
gonna put Simplicity zoom on and request
Central Plus
okay so now that we've defined
presenting scheme and the type of loss
that we're interested in we can rewrite
iron paper with minimization I I don't
see where your sampling procedure even
enters here no it enters here right this
is the last option
so we we have two ingredients to be able
to define a focused magnetization we
need to define the sampling scheme and
then we lost function the sampling
scheme is if you want uh we waiting for
loss so you're going to look at every
vertex every vertex u and v then you're
going to look at the loss between the uh
corresponding to the embedding vectors
and the file that are connected or not
and then you're we waiting results by
how what's the probability that you
observe them in a sub sample
and different something scheme will here
give you different type of probabilities
and so different type of ways
today and so this is how we are going to
want to choose our embedding vectors is
that clear more or less
okay and so our goal is to go now now
that we've defined how we are sampling
uh how we are drawing our embeddings we
want to understand what type of
properties of a graph are we learning
uh can we what are we imagine
corresponding to is have a consistent uh
what is if yes what is the weight of
convergence uh what is the impact of a
choice of our hyper parameters so for
example what is the impact of the trust
of the sampling skin
etc etc so um there was some previous
work looking at the performance of not
today most of them however were looking
at a performance when the uh embedding
space was of similar Dimension than the
number of vertices which is a very
different setting than Note 2 back is
usually considered in and are made over
and with a stick assumption I want to
point out to a later work by also about
who looked at the properties of flow to
vac and Depot for Community detection in
this first class setting
and this is a very interesting paper so
I encourage you to look at it so we're
going to answer those questions for
exchangeable graphs some of this have
already been we also generalized some of
those or two graphics and we expect the
others to be generalizable
so I know that everyone in this room is
familiar with exchange but well but to
do an exchangeable graph you're going to
choose a guacam which is a function that
Maps the unit Square to the unit
interval and then you're going to draw a
sequence of iog uh when available
uniformly at random and then you're
going to sample connect.s is you and
connect SSV with a probability of w
Lambda U Lambda B
and so this is the traditional way of
building an exchangeable graph
we know that exchangeable graphs tend to
be dense and so to be able to look at
response setting a popular method is to
specify the grapher and so that means
that if you want to draw a graph of size
n what you could do is that you could
connect the vertices unb with a smaller
probability of whole n of w point times
the W from time and the smaller this
whole n is going to tend to be those
possible graph is going to tend to be so
this is the type of networks that we are
studying and we are doing we are doing
so under the hypothesis but this whole
and can go to you if it wants to but as
I throw away the log of n divided by n
so we're not looking at that setting
so the first Insight that we had to try
to make sense of all of this was to
notice that when you're sampling over an
exchangeable graph
the probability that two vertices I and
J are in your subsample
really only depends if and if a
photograph is very light on local
features of you of your graph so let's
make sure let's try to gain some
nutrition of this imagine that your
symptoms are foreign k
and then you sample L over vertices with
a probability that depends on the degree
of those vertices
and then you look at the end result buff
you think about it the problem is you
have a certain Edge
UMD is sampled what does it depend on if
whether quality would um in the first in
the one or more for example this is an
example it will depend on what it would
depend on the degree of you the degree
of v and if there was an edge to start
with right
but now in exchangeable graph we know
that the degree is concentrate
and so the degree of U is approximable
by a function that only depends on the
local feature of you
now the probability that the vertices
are not the edge is sampled is a bit
more complex to to write down but you
can show similarly that it will only
depend you can approximate it by
something that will only depend on the
local feature of you local feature of v
and before there was an edge or not
so this is the type of sampling scheme
that we want to look at we want to look
at sampling scheme with this kind of
like local averaging effect happens so
that the probability that two vertices
are included in my cell work can be
approximated by a function but only
depends on the local features of of my
vertices
and I'm going to call this function FM
here the sampling weight and then we
show that for more sampling procedures
that are interested in machine learning
and statistics these properties is
indeed respected and we compute the
respective sampling weight
so why is this useful so if you remember
we wanted to choose our embedding
vectors to follow minimize this
following empirical average
now imagine that mind matching vectors
are fixed for the moment I'm not doing
any optimization
my if a something scheme is kind of
locally averaging by definition I could
try this is approximately the same thing
as if I replace my probability by my
sampling weights
and so it would take this nice form here
now we are an exchangeable glass so
there's a lot of averaging and
concentration happening
and so we can probably with uh there's
going to be another averaging that is
going to happen here around the Chrome
clips that you're gonna make and so uh
this
uh formula is going to approximately be
equal to this much simpler empirical
average you can prove this using
concentration in practice here we are in
the case we've been bending betas are
fixed okay
and then it's much simpler formula you
notice that it depends only on what the
underlying features of my vectors right
so imagine that I was not
Choosing My embedding by minimizing RN I
was instead using them choosing them by
sampling oh yes uh for Simplicity for
words of a stock I'm going to denote F
till the end with FN times WN so you can
think of this as a re-weighted buffer
and the way reaching here what happens
is by my sampling weights and these
suppose I got to change depending on my
sampling scheme and some of the
different sampling schemes are going to
produce different F to this and we're
going to go back on this influence later
but uh yes
all right so in these random walk
schemes and so on then a priority the
probability we observe a pair depends uh
partly on how how far apart they are
topologically in the graph right because
but you're saying that that's in this
graph on model that's something that
again undercomes just on yeah okay yes
it's kind of how we end up at the end of
the day only depends on sometimes
okay great
um and so imagine that instead of
minimizing the initial random walk uh
empirical risk I was minimizing this
simpler empirical risk then because this
only depends on the local features I
would kind of expect My Chosen embedding
vectors to only depend on the local
features
and so I would expect that the embedding
the dot product between my embedding
vectors would be a DOT product of local
functions of Lambda U and lamw
and so if I was looking at the
population limit the empirical risk you
would only depend on those underlying
features right yes
can you all determine this location yes
of course yes so you can only thank you
for very much this is something I cannot
zoom over but yes uh be because I lost
function only depends on the other
product they are defined up to
prediction
um and so
uh and so we would expect them to only
depend on the local features and so
we're gonna I'm so I'm gonna hear uh
write down all the function okay that
can be written as a DOT product between
function of local embeddings
and then I'm going to denote like this
you said all of us possible uh functions
that can be written in this way you have
a positive is because of a DOT product
okay this is just another Edition and so
we expect the population risk
who would have a spoon
now obviously I've been telling you all
of this story assuming that I'm
minimizing a very simple form this is
not the case right we are the
imperialism minimizing is not this
simple idealized purpose and so we could
expect that the true uh minimize we
could be very far away from the
population risk and this would be an
example of overfitting we show that
under certain technical condition this
doesn't happen and we characterize the
weight of convergence
and then
okay
uh but more interestingly what can we
say not only about the risk but about
the embedding vectors themselves and
what about this dot product here between
those embedding vectors those appear
everywhere in the last so surely we
should improve like carry on some
information
in the paper we answer both questions uh
improve interest of time I'm just gonna
answer the second question today feel
free to talk to me about the first
question there's a lot of interesting
things that happen about a second
question that's why I wanted to zoom out
this
so I just argued that I should tell you
that the general condition the uh
empirical minimizing people is close to
the minimum of a population risk maybe
the minimizer should also be close to
each other so the natural question is
what does we minimize the of a
population okay so now imagine that I
was not restricting what type of
function came looking at I'm looking at
any potential symmetric function does
not need to be written as a DOT product
then uh because here we are looking at
the cross Center Pilots constantropy
loss the optimal choice for our sampling
uh for KN okay would take this form
so to try to gain some nutrition on this
let's look at what happens if my
settling scheme is sampling towards the
caveat is that line down and looking at
the inducer graph
then the minimum of a population
minimizer can be Rewritten as a sigma
weight inverse of the guapro and so if
you knew KN if you were able to estimate
the population minimizer you would be
able to learn everything you want about
your weapon you would be able for
example to do a link prediction let's
say
now different sampling schemes are going
to allow you to read to learn instead
related version of a graph mode and what
it says exactly and so and different
properties about this so we talk about
this at length uh in the paper and at
the end of the truth I'm gonna
uh say something about how I think this
can be useful for example to do fairness
on graphs
but this is to give you some intuition
so uh now obviously we are not
minimizing uh over any arbitrary
function K we're asking them to be
looking like the products
and so this um this population minimizer
is not always uh something that is a
possible uh choice and so if I look if I
do uh I can value extension of my my
Global minimizer there will be two cases
that we're going to be looking at
first case is when the world is
beautiful and all vegan values are
positive
and we are going to be able to cover KN
and then there's a case where this is
not and then this is going to be an
example of how why doing Theory
sometimes leads to change your choice of
uh method
so in the first case where everything is
beautiful
and under some technical conditions we
can prove that yes indeed
you will not pro you can learn this
population minimizer and that the dot
product between will run and badging
battles will converge with three scale
so for example if I'm doing uh I'm
sampling my vertices with replacement
and looking at BNG subgraph
I will be converging to this function
that only depends on the platform
and so I'm going to learn the platform
we also give exact weight of conversions
that will depend on the dimension D the
choice of sampling scheme and how nice
your guacan is
now what happens in the case where not
Everything Is Beautiful
well you uh there's no way that this
population this population minimizer
will not belong to the space that you
are constraining yourself to to try to
minimize over so you are not going to be
able to learn it your investing vectors
are still going to convert to something
and we can still characterize what it is
but there's going to be a lack of uh
injectivity you'll be some information
that is lost
so let me give you uh an example of this
uh so for example imagine that we are
doing uh looking at a stochastic block
model with two communities of equal size
and that the probability that
um the the probability that they're
connected inside the uh on the diagonal
is p and we probably even then connected
utterly diagonal noise Q okay imagine
we're working as this instead
and assume that P is bigger than two
this is natural and P is plus two is
Trick is smaller than one then I can
tell you that the line embeddings
without product between them will
converge I know what it is it will
converge to this quantity
but notice here by this limit only
depends on the difference between p and
Q
so there's no way I can download the the
uh what the actual uh stochastic block
model was
and so this you can still do community
detection because uh the sign for
example we depend on the fact that they
belong to a security or not but you're
not going to be able to do link
prediction for example
and this is a problem because uh when we
when machine learning people are
building those methods they're building
it to be usable on many different tasks
not only on one task so this information
loss here is problematic so is
everything lost
no not necessarily you could instead of
minimizing every to to do everything by
minimizing having the laws that depend
only on the dot product you can have
your loss depending on requiring in a
product and I forgot to clean this
formula but the kind in a product is
simply the differences between two
different
uh dark purposes
and so here this will allow you to learn
okay like functions but if you don't
have negating again values
and then I can show it tell you that
indeed
uh if we train our embedding vectors
using Instead This crying in a product
uh requiring a product between our
learning buildings will converge
and instead they will come and they will
accomplish a population minimizing
quantity and so for example if you are
sampling uh K vertices and looking at
the end your sub graph you are indeed
learning the guava
and so probably it's better to actually
use this crime in the product uh instead
of the regular dot product when you are
building your method at least
theoretically speaking uh we checked if
this is also the case for the Italian
says yes so we have a series of
experimental demandatory data set and as
well as real data set so this experiment
here is for two different data set one
is we put in protein into Action Network
the other one is a Blog Network
um and then we are looking at
we are doing our embedding method using
remember there will be sampling scheme
we are looking at different choices of
sampling schemes and then we are
training our model with a loss that
depends either only on the dot product
or on the corner product
and then we are looking at the effort
schools and the bigger vehicles the
happier you are and here you can see
we're doing Bitcoin in a product always
outperforms
so hereby doing Theory we kind of like
discovered
a new uh a way to improve your
methodologies that works in practice
and now because yes
did you know the parameters right down
the no you you don't repeat the question
so to be able she wants to know if you
need to know where parameters of black
mother to be able to learn to choose the
equivalent product
right no you don't you'd simply gonna
make in both cases to be able to get
convergence you're going to need to look
at potentially growing dimension
and here until you're gonna simply make
the dimension a group arbitrarily slowly
within and then you're going to be able
to chew it but I thought that the
operator s inside the crime inner
product had something to do with the uh
so here you can choose you can make it
uh you can choose this p and choose my
smart do that we just simply consider uh
p and Q to be equal to 64 and 64. so
that the dimension of the two problem is
also the same oh that had nothing to do
with that those p's and q's
in the block is it no it has nothing to
do thank you sorry no no bad choice of
notation I'm so sorry bachelor's
annotations
we also give uh consistency results for
the embedding vectors themselves
and then give some early guarantee so
that stream task is more work to be done
with this yes
so I have a question on your sampling
and what I thought of my intuition about
is about sparse graphs so if you if you
just chose K random vertices you would
typically get a disconnected graph in
the I mean you would just see no a
single edge in the
sub-sampled graphing model yeah you're
gonna you're gonna see very few of them
yes so how can you be able to prove
something using that sampling method so
uh here this will be for the case of uh
that was in the case where it does it
didn't go to zero this was just to give
some use of nutrition and in the case
where we're looking at the sparse
Network actually we have had the random
walk is usually the thing you want to do
so and if you do the random walk yeah
then I actually don't know of much
results how sort of this sampling
schemes of random walks for
so we have I mean we have some idea what
the sample scheme of benjamini SRAM
which is sort of doing balls does in the
boundary degree but the sampling scheme
of random walk does I'm less sure and
I'm even less sure about what it does if
I'm not in the settings
and I can show you a formula or if
you're not offline but I forgot
something I didn't okay but can you give
me some intuition while this should work
why so it depends on what you mean by
should work right you're not going to
learn the original platform you're going
to learn a related version of this
classroom uh and so these uh and so we
the the intuition of I don't know what
is that you remember but uh notably
you're gonna observe that uh the
graphene we waited weapon that you're
gonna learn is actually going to be in
this case independent of these past
parameters pacifying uh parameter for n
and this is probably why during random
works on uh on Spotify is actually so
powerful in practice
end up not depending on your specifying
Factor if you're doing a random work
sentence
okay so uh
I promise you that we would and so now
we so we give some other some certain uh
conditions we gave
um we learned what the embedding vectors
we present and give some high
probability of the our guarantees about
it now can we learn the distribution of
Australian embeddings
well obviously this is a very tricky
question because it's not uh I couldn't
help myself they it's not a linear
function of uh anymore it's complex
function of a graph right and so this
kind of enters into a bigger question
which is how do you learn uh and what
conditional General function of an
exchangeable
is asymptotic under which condition it's
not
so uh I so here I met so imagine that
you have a random object X
if it is uh environment under an action
of the symmetrical permutation group so
this is the same setting that you saw in
yesterday Peter's talk so this could be
for example an exchange of a graph it
could be an exchangeable partition
exchangeable sequence Etc and then one
you want to know under what condition
a function of this uh geometry
exchangeable of this exchangeable object
and the word condition is going to be
asymptotically normal
and so it's going to be asymptotically
normal and the condition that I clean my
side properly and that is
but this is an actual code of weather
not just through letter word
and so it's going to be effectively
normal under the condition that FN
doesn't depend too much on if you want a
small change it doesn't change too much
if I make small changes to X so if a
case where you're looking at an
exchangeable sequence
uh for example if you instead of
observing X1 or J X N you had observed x
n plus one and X20 x n which has the
same distribution you would want the
difference between the two to be kind of
small this can be made for more for
exchangeable objects in general by using
permutations but this is kind of the
intuition this is not enough this is
enough to get concentration it's not to
get to get a central material you're
going to need something a bit more
you're going to need that how to to know
about how big this change is doesn't
depend too much on other parts of your
number objects so that for example if
instead of observing X2 until xn you had
observe xn plus two until xn
when the diff this difference here when
you change the impact of changing this
exponent to this X and plus one would be
the same would be close it would be two
not two decimal
this is obviously true if you are
looking at an empirical language because
this difference would now become
independent of X2
but uh the you but it's not necessarily
true for more complex functions for
functions and you're going to want to
you're going to need that this
difference is not too big
and so you can once again there's this
formula for General exchangeable object
by using permutations
and then this is a bit technical uh but
uh you in my physics I proved that
indeed uh and it was a general condition
then your function of your exchangeable
object is at some particularly normal
and then you can generalize this
triangular ways
how far so we proved this using a
martingal method and so sadly we don't
have a weight of convergence and a
natural question would be can we for
example characterize how fast would this
converge uh using the vessel strength
distance in Peter's talk yesterday you
saw that using which time method we
could characterize how fast this
converges in the last structure in one
distance there has also been an interest
increasing interest in statistics
machine learning for looking at
vasostyle P distances and I just wanted
to just uh mention it at the end of my
talk
and uh so can you also characterize this
for example how fast do essential
material Imports for work moment in the
vessels and P distance for General piece
this is not a trivial question uh in the
case where you have a sequence of ID
random variables that are centered
um
it was proven in 2009 by a few of that
he obtained a wait for this for the
central emission for in the wp distance
for P that was smaller than two and then
he conjectured but such a weight could
be also obtained for BP given two uh how
to do it in general was open for a long
time and it was answered by bonus and uh
World Cup sorry but proved the bad under
General condition with Versace distance
would be of a weight of one of n or one
over n and they use very interesting
methods uh he uses Stein exchangeable
permission and use an edge work
extension but both of those methods were
not very amenable to dependent data and
so there was no weight known for the for
dependent data and so uh with a PhD
student uh Liu at Harvard we just uh
recently pulled but indeed you can get
also a WP bound
for General empirical average of
dependent data and so notably it allows
you to get WP band for black moments as
well as as for random fields and then
the depends how fast is the switch will
depend on the dependent structure that
you have okay I'm sorry for the tensions
I just couldn't help myself at liking it
films a lot a bit too much
thank you for your time and uh thank you
for listening
[Applause]
okay
questions
uh so yeah very interesting talk so um
so I guess the work which we showed that
in some regime sort of you know the
backtracking propensity of note to work
does better than like default so this is
important so do these sorts of things
pop out of your analysis so this was a
this is something that we actually
didn't think about and I uh still think
about after I talked about two weeks so
the answer we just didn't look at it we
could answer we could look at those uh
questions by Computing both different
sampling weights we just haven't thought
about doing that okay thanks and I guess
the other question so as you rightly
said you know the the pipeline for these
embedding algorithms is a huge pipeline
they run like uh noise contrast of
estimation then they do the stochastic
gradient descent etc etc so do you have
any insight into whether your results
can like give insight into what's
actually being used in practice because
the optimization methods they use are
non-convex etc etc yeah so you're
talking about for example can we say
something I'm not sure to understand
questions I'm going to rephrase it and
you can correct me can we could say
something also about the Inquisition
that is going to come from a stochastic
wages and decent path right I mean in
applications the way that these things
are implemented you're doing this
especially no we haven't looked at that
okay and this is something I think uh I
think my co-oper is looking at but I'm
not sure Focus this is we have some
small insights but
um I don't know how much weight I can
give to it and so we should talk offline
but we have some results about it in our
paper but where we can say something
about the variance of the sgg depending
on the sampling scheme
thank you for a very nice talk um I'm
wondering if you can comment on how this
compares to fitting a latent variable
model which is what people would do in
statistics typically where you would
postulate
um these embedding coordinates as latent
variables that you don't know and you
have some explicit probability
of links resulting from this and you
have a likelihood how you maximize it as
a separate question but would you say
that this is just
a computational
way to maximize such a thing if you
could match your empirical risk to
likelihood or is it somehow
fundamentally I think the the different
search but it's important to look at is
the wall of a something scheme it's not
revealed to me to exactly like the
Selfies team here is actually a
non-trivial ingredient of this it's not
just or we use it to be able to do
stochastic gradient descent what you
learn depends a lot on your sampling
scheme and so for and so
um how this how is this interesting this
is uh I think a question that depends a
lot on the type of graph you look at and
so I think just if I if I give you a
model could you then adapt the sampling
scheme or this approach to fit a model
probably yes but it would it or would it
really depend on what the model is and
how the life so you can learn a lot of
things about it but yes indeed when you
when you look at the something steam if
you're not learning the underlying model
always you're learning some for example
you're not learning the Android phone
sometimes you're learning some
re-weighted version of a graphic
and so it's not trivial to me to see
exactly which sampling Siemens which
we're waiting to invest
ments
that's true
so a follow-up which I think it's a
follow-up I may just be restating I'm
not sure so one kind of graph on is
where I give you some Distribution on
some manifold maybe on the sphere if you
want to stick to unit vectors and so on
and then I have a geometric random graph
type model where the probability of a
link depends on the inner product or
something
so it sounds like what you just said to
Lisa is that this wouldn't necessarily
recover it wouldn't necessarily be
consistent in the sense
what you're saying you can correct me so
you first have some type of uh like
embedding into a dimensional space and
then you have a guacamole that will
depend on those underlying feature and
the dimensional space and then you want
to recover this probability right and
the graph on might literally be a
function of the inner product for
instance yes so you will recovered in
certain scheme and for others you will
not you can design something scheme in
which you can't recover it and you can
design something skimming under which
you will for example if you sample K
vertices at random and look at me you
still go up and you will recover it if
you're doing a well-on walk you're
recovering a weighted version of it and
uh this uh we waited version of it can
have some nicer properties in certain
setting but it's not exact but it's not
clear to me exactly why best is what you
want to learn I think an interesting
angle also to look at it is I'm not
answering your question anymore I'm
diverging back onto something I said and
I didn't end up saying which is for
example if you uh if I I think there's a
mismatch okay let me be honest I think
it's a mismatch here between the tools
that we are looking at which is we are
studying this for foreign exchangeable
models
and and what is actually happening in
practice and the truth is that with
method and why the certain sampling
schemes work so well for Recovery might
be also due to the true way those models
are generally uh produced and not
produced for an exchangeable graph now
if you have an exchangeable one you want
to sample K vertices and look at the
news about this is not often not the
best way to do it in practice and then I
think why this is not the best thing to
do in practice is just simply byproduct
of fact that we are not exactly like our
assumptions are interesting and allow us
to learn about something but they're not
the white one like we're not matching
the reality
I guess one awkward thing about some
some geometric graph models is they're
not this sort of sparsification of a
graphite rather they have an order one
probability so when this setting is
looking at okay so the setting yeah
it's actually a simpler question than
that but you said you need some
Lipschitz continuity now if you require
lipsticks continuity on the interval 01
you really restrict your word so you
might actually want to say you have some
Rd as your underlying space for the
graph on D being not necessary or
embedding Dimension and have lipses on
that so we consider holder by part and
we also consider the dimensional space I
just didn't presented but we also
consider in the paper of a case where
instead of having to graph on them the
unit interval to Z1 we it Maps a
three-dimensional space 201
platform instead and say it all and they
are also that there's some type of like
holder bipart type organization
[Applause]